like so let me ask you like what's the
point of war to take over someone else's
property base resources
yeah restore the reefs or it could be
ideological alright but we're at an age
now where you can win a war without even
lifting a finger no you can just
convince these have to pick up the phone
or write maybe hit a button alright you
don't got to pick up a weapon yeah good
plan is mightier than the sword so I was
thinking about this we you can what
we're seeing with all this like election
meddling stuff and like you know fake
social media and sock puppets it's more
effective to manipulate the public and
to try into believing you than it is to
actually go and force them to do
anything yeah like it's actually
interesting I don't if you've played the
new civilization No so in there's
there's a couple ways you can take over
cities and one of them is through
cultural pressure basically if your
society civilization has like massive
cultural output eventually you'll put
your boundaries will be pushing on
another city who will then basically
revolt and join you yeah okay so if you
successfully convince an entire
population that you're better and they
should live the way you want to live
they're gonna want to be like you as
much as they can and then you can take
away the power of that government
through cultural export I mean I I see
parallels with what's going on China
right now because there can they're
trying to convince their citizens that
the u.s. dropped it in Wuhan and that's
that's what happened and then there's
videos of Chinese citizens probably
risking death to like send it out like
we don't trust the CCP either right we
we're not happy here we all can't stand
what's going on we know it came from
here take a look at this I had a bunch
of we had a bunch of people messaging in
the chat saying that there was some some
pro China youtuber making videos about
me right yeah I don't wanna say the
guy's name I don't know who he is I
write about him I don't have any issue
with him personally but he's Pro China
right it makes sense I'm Pro America not
Pro China I view China's adversarial to
the United States and I view them as
doing really horrible horrible things
yeah I'm sure there are people over
there that view America the same way
like they want China to win yeah so then
you get a pro Chinese youtuber who makes
videos saying you know I'm a conspiracy
theorist and I believe crazy things and
I think the u.s. is coming for me
clearly
attempt to manipulate and discredit me
yeah because I put out a story where I
one of the things he said was was I read
an article where it said US intelligence
agencies leak show that China has been
lying about the kovat numbers I read
that story I believe that story and so
he said I was a conspiracy theorist
because his view is that US media is
lying and I shouldn't believe it and
he's Pro China and his viewers are all
Chinese that's the game right now I'm
you know I'm a useful idiot I guess for
the u.s. for the United States because I
like America because I want America to
win yeah so the content I make will be
very much you know Pro America and
that's bad for America's enemies so
they'll counter it with their own
propaganda but propaganda at this point
is way more powerful if it's actually
it's almost inverted if a soldier like
think about false flags right do you
guys know about the operation Northwoods
mmm this was back in I think it was the
60s where man I'm gonna mess up and I
know a lot of people who are listening
probably know what I'm talking about a
guy named like L Lemnitzer or L LM
that's or something proposed dressing up
people like Cuban soldiers and then
attacking Florida to so that people
would hate Cuba it's called the false
flag and then apparently the whole thing
was scrapped like no way we're not gonna
do this yeah okay so if a Chinese
soldier was seen on camera violating the
rights of somebody that's a negative
you know prop that's negative propaganda
for them it's a bad people say I don't
want to have anything to do with that
right if they put out videos where
they're like helping children drink
water and like saving lives and like
building bridges that's good so if they
actually engaged in war and we filmed
about crashing on the shores and a bunch
of soldiers coming out and you know
gunning down civilians it would be a
major negative event around the world
because of the spread of information it
used to be that war was was quiet and no
one really knew was going on yeah and
because no one knew the US would be like
our heroic soldiers stopped the evil and
everyone would believe it now we have
film yet we have you know we have the
events filmed yeah it was I think in
2014 was the first time we had GoPro
footage from both sides of a conflict
there's a camera mounted on a tank and a
camera mounted on a few in rival
infantrymen when they filmed both sides
and up low
and the news organization found both and
put them together like you can watch
both sides of the conflict cow now
because of the spread of information you
can't get away with these atrocities no
like there's no way you know the u.s.
nuked Hiroshima and Nagasaki there's no
way that could happen this time the
whole world would watch in horror and
disgust agreed but it took a while for
people to find out what at least I want
I really want to believe that there
theoretically someone could launched an
ICBM and no one would claim
responsibility for it
yeah but then we would be alike us would
be like we know it came from here and
then everyone on the world would
probably know yeah I feel like
propaganda almost is losing its its edge
though because people aren't going for
you know cult the classic news sources
you know they're they're going to
YouTube there they're finding the people
like you for example that are like I I'm
just reading everything and giving you
my you know view on it and it's not
necessarily this is not necessarily this
but this is what I've found you know
this is the truth that I've found and
people are taking taking everything more
with a grain of salt because it's too
obvious that everyone's skewing
everything to try to like you know push
their bias opinion you know yeah but in
terms of that that's that's very much
like local pilot like American politics
okay if they I'm thinking very in
American that's a good point yeah yeah
if the Democrats you you've got like
progressive youtubers a little bit Oh
harm these conservatives and then you'll
have conservative Oh Haram fees you know
liberals and then you'll have moderates
like you know Oh Haram whoever and
that's very internal but I don't there's
there's no progressive or lefty or
Sanders supporter or even social justice
activist who has said anything negative
to me as far as I can tell over my
criticisms of China they don't care
they're out there they're focused on
internal issues the the person who came
out and was mad at me you know calling
me all these names was a Pro China
youtuber apparently like a big
personality in China for obvious reasons
yeah makes sense so the real issue is we
do have internal political conflict but
I definitely think our foreign
adversaries exploit that
and try to make us fight each other more
so he can't be focused on fighting them
but now that we have this pandemic it's
been pretty bad because everyone's kind
of leaning more towards China bad yeah
we're a lot of reasons you know you know
it still the media hates Trump so much
and this is really dangerous for us I
think you know I really love about all
of the like the super anti government
conspiracy theorists people is that the
government can't even get a control over
all of this it's like you really think
the government you know in all of its
different functions and forms and
divisions is in control enough if like
if that was the case then they would
they would get rid of all of the anti
America sentiment which is rampant and
insane yeah and they're like oh it's
Russia they're smearing us and they're
doing all these things and it's like you
can't even stop a few hat 13 hackers in
Russia who spent a few thousand dollars
and then not everyone's complaining
about it they're not they're not the US
government has got power in a lot of
ways but they are not some all-powerful
Illuminati entity twirling their
mustaches I'm sure there's a lot of
things they do that would surprise you
and you'd be like wow I can't believe
they do that but when you've got you
know got adversarial conflict right now
but the way it is with like China you'd
think the US government would be alike
we need propaganda that's Pro America
and people who are disruptive to America
should be stopped I don't they don't do
anything like that I still can't believe
that the media hasn't like spread the
the whole China was bringing in these
these diseases for the past five years
that's number one Department of Justice
report right how how is the media not
reporting on that spreading that like
telling not spreading it because that it
feels like spreading lies but like
that's actually a report from the
Department of Justice like you know you
don't I don't understand
you know ABC News did well they ran a
story claiming that sources say that
back in November they reported to you
know White House officials that there
was this outbreak coming and then the
what is it the the National Center for
medical intelligence of a it's called
said no such report exists ABC ran with
the story anyway because sources say I
don't know who the sources are why you'd
believe them and you didn't
publish any documents so why should I
believe you when the actual people there
said that's not true and China was lying
about this in January and only found out
in December why would why should I
believe that your unnamed sources know
better than the actual officials
speaking out why should I trust the the
random nobodies that's what the media's
been doing good point
it's really bad for America unless
there's something I don't understand and
there's a grand conspiracy fine sure
whatever but right now you've got a
media that is damaging the credibility
of the US government you know that is
spreading lies that hurt the ability of
the US government to respond to things
well you know what we got serious
problems you know in terms of
international conflict especially in the
South China Sea I agree and
unfortunately we we we there is no I
mean I'm saying this is a joke there's
no grand you know All American military
militaristic conspiracy to control
everything it's just it would be so much
more efficient for the u.s. cough
droughts adversaries if that if that was
a real thing
you know even when it comes to like
Hillary Clinton in the Qatar Turkey
pipeline and all that nonsense with
Ukraine that's that was going on they
didn't even do a great job of it you
know it's not even it's just it's just
you know agendas and people and these
things change in government if we if we
had a more efficient authoritarian
government we have a much easier time of
going up against China like they do
against us yeah or containing the krona
virus if we should believe them by
welding people's doors shut and leaving
me to die in their houses yeah yeah we
can't do that here so you know what if
we were unified as a as a country and it
feels like we are we are unifying now
well I think so I think at the end of
this we're gonna be much more together
than we were before
yeah possibly and I I think we'll be a
lot better about ignoring the media
because we'll have watched them lie to
us straight left right and center I
think I think come November mm-hmm I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it right now make a
bet I could be absolutely wrong about
this because it's very early but I feel
like based on everything's happened so
far come November especially with Joe
Biden we very well may see a mass
majority of this country rally behind
Trump and the administration his poll
ratings will skyrocket I don't know for
sure I know it feels like it's a strong
possibility at least as far as what I
scene with his poles climbing better
than they've ever been there are a lot
of people who really really hate the guy
but you you've got Bernie Sanders
supporters who hate the DNC you know got
Trump supporters hey at the DNC so
already they got a common enemy Joe
Biden is a joke I don't know if they
were thinking I agree
but with the with the pandemic as bad as
it is I mean you see what Chris Hayes
said no today no wonder so they came out
revived dr. Fauci and Burkes revised
their numbers down from 240 K to 60 K
Dow or a hundred whichever whichever
library the projected numbers yeah okay
so without social distancing they were
saying like 2 million or more right with
social distancing they were saying
200,000 now they're saying based on
current numbers it looks like 60 and
chris hayes says the most cynical you
know thing i can i can see and i really
don't want to believe it or something
like that is that they they've fluffed
the numbers up higher to anchor everyone
to that number so that when the numbers
were lower people would think they did a
good job
are you insane what right it's like how
about the reason the number like dr.
Burks is the one who made the number up
are you accusing doctor I'm sorry dr.
Brooks and fatty are you accusing these
doctors of creating fake numbers so they
would look good they're not even elected
officials they're appointed as far as I
can tell would that make them look good
terrible yeah terrifying these people
are weirdos Chris Hayes all I can think
of if that's a significantly smaller
number think I'm so thankful right and
it's still poor funny people are gonna
die yeah it sucks but 260 thousand is
way better than 200,000 like that's the
only thing I can think of in cycle so
wait we're we're gonna put blame on them
because they fluffed the numbers
come on but the main issue is just that
there are people who hate the president
so much yeah they will say these things
but here's what I'm thinking I don't
believe Chris Hayes actually knows or
cares I think he's just trying to say
things because that's what he's supposed
to say here's my tribe here's what must
be bad that's the media for you so what
happens if we have a really serious
catastrophe be like the you know Kovac
gets worse or something and then Trump
really does do a good job what's
surprising to me is that even after the
polls
the majority of polls are coming out in
favor in Trump's favor the the the
response from these people in media is
this can't be real I refuse to believe
it
and impeach him right well Alyssa Milano
said she should be impeached her news
that wasn't even real that and that's
another thing too like Snopes factoring
in the new york times yeah
like maybe we are unifying the cold day
maybe right yeah it really does feel
like it so maybe by november we might be
shocked to see and i could be absolutely
wrong about this there's so much that
could happen from now and then that's
another thing that really annoys me
about you know these activists would
like to go back and look at things you
said to make it you out of context to
make it look like you're stupid I know
because hindsight is 20/20 this that's
that's what that that's what bugs me
also you know it's like people have to
know you're allowed to make mistakes
humans make mistakes and we learn from
them that's why we've been around as
long as we have because we've learned
from our mistakes well it's not even
about mistakes either it's like right
now I'm saying man I think Trump might
have a really high approval rating and
then a month from now
Trump walks out and to Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody yeah you know like that's
this famous thing he was I gotta walk
out of fifth and then someone's like
well Tim said that he's got a really
good approval rating he's doing great
and look he's shot a man it's like right
yeah but that was that was a month no
one before shot somebody exactly yeah
and they're like where you at no to him
you think he's going to get like I did
he didn't you didn't do that when I said
I said that's why I'm like base of
everything we're seeing now yeah is he
is he perfect far from it but the
American people are generally approving
Democrats and independents have to have
a higher approval rating of him in his
response to the coronavirus I think
depending on how bad this gets and how
fast we can pull out of it I mean
economy is rebounding people we the CDC
has already said people who are exposed
can start getting back to work we might
recover from this and people might say
Trump was the leader when it happened
and they might rally behind him you know
I still think you're gonna have a very
strong contingent of orange man bad
types yeah boy look man look what Joe
Rogan said he'd rather have Trump over
Biden I am inclined to agree
I mean yeah yeah look people have argued
that Trump has dementia and all the
stuff and it's like you're only saying
that because he talks weird like Trump
has he says weird things like big league
you know or big Li or whatever it is and
I mean I make up my own words I'm
serious I do all the time not fun Trump
does talk weird
yeah you know it's like he's like it's
the the adjectives he used in the ways
he describes things it's the best
medication it's very big
it's great then you're like okay I
understand me but that's not dementia
that's just him being a can eccentric
strange billionaire you know I mean
mm-hmm Joe Biden says words but it don't
make sentences and someone posted uh I
think was like a med rx thing about word
salad that when people are in the early
stages of dementia they start saying
words they're real words but they don't
make sense in their sentences well that
reminds me of a certain some somebody
running for president right now oh yeah
Joe Biden for those wondering if it
wasn't clear there is no honest person
who really believes that guy could be
President III I am I am flabbergasted by
these Democrats who are like Yahoo Joe
Biden why yeah just get what Atwater is
policy positions doe doesn't know you
see what Tucker Carlson said the other
day he said here's some serious
questions that need to be asked could
Joe Biden find his car in a three-tiered
parking lot could he navigate a salad
bar like no I mean the fact that we're
asking these questions is a problem well
listen the salad bar thing was silly
yeah three-tiered parking garage isn't
no it's not you're right like you know
come on we walk out of the storm like oh
man where we park and then it takes a
quick second like ah there we are
yeah Joe it yeah it's it's like yeah I
want to think that it's a joke but the
fact that it's actually serious it's
like oh come on Joe here's here's a tire
man for sure but on Twitter and Twitter
isn't real life the progressives is this
is this is the crazy thing like I'm
looking at mainstream blue cheeky
journalists tweeting don't vote for
Trump or Biden that to me what's the
difference
no no they're saying don't vote I mean
like you could vote third party for sure
and and I respect people who vote
outside of to party because I think
voting on principle is the most
important thing I'd rather vote third
party even if I thought I was going to
lose because I knew I said I'm a
principal but set telling people not to
vote because you're mad Bernie losts
okay Trump's got a landslide yeah for
real man
want to act like literally every
American is know we're at trump hat and
go around singing I think we're gonna
we're gonna see a lot of Democrats and
independents being like me I'll vote for
the guy don't like him though and I
think we're gonna end up seeing Trump
win it might be like Nixon in his
reelection or or Reagan when they got
like 500 electoral votes I don't know
though you know I really hate saying
things like this because I well actually
I hate saying them but I do love to go
back like hindsight you that you're
right yeah like my video where I'm like
Republicans are gonna sweep the house in
2018 the Democrats are gonna lose and
the next day I'm like well about that
well I was wrong I was wrong about that
one way off well it's good to admit you
you're wrong that's why I don't like
making predictions you know I'm a buddy
I can't see the future you know I mean
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you